sẽ tải trở tán phải hai tấn gạo dời xuống sông thuật lốt sau khi nghiệp chính cầu vang người thẳng từ bị sập,
cây dễ kiếp thắt dàng ngoài.
Pòa gánh dở vang người, sẽ tải trải trên tình lộ chính hai một khi qua cầu vang người thẳng từ,
phường thuận hơn, bất ngờ nghiệp chính cầu sập xuống,
cầu có tải trọng cho phép tán tấn trong khi sẽ trở tán phải hai tấn gạo.
Tại hình trường một lâu nghiệp cầu chim xuống kênh, lâu còn lại, gắc lên chủ bé tông,
nửa thân sẽ tải chim giữ nước, dều bao gạo dời vậy xuống sông.
Hạ chắc, bây giờ sẽ tải trở tải trở tải trở,
cầu a cháy để ngảy kéo mức.
Đồ mẹ là ngưu phòng uống phạt thi, cháy gạo, không trởi quá đợi hả đợi.
Cầu bác người thẳng từ dài sống bây mết, kết cầu chủ về tông,
nghiệp thép, xây dự hình hình hình hình lắm nằm,
gồm hai lần xem mấy bối bên một phẩy nằm mết,
và một lần ổ tô bà phy nằm mết,
cầu bác qua thuyến sông dài nằm mê ba kilomet,
trảy giọt an rằng và cần thơ trước khi đổ ra sâu hậu.
Sự cố khiến người dân ở hybên cầu,
phải đi đừng vào 8 đến 4 kilomet,
lực lượng chức năng đang chục bất xe và nghiệp cầu,
dài thoảng luận chó sà lăn, tầu thuên qua lại,
đông thời điều tra quyết nhân vụ việc.